si vous habitez une grande ville
peut-être avez-vous déjà remarqué un
dimanche par exemple dans les rues vides
ou à la terrasse d'un café un homme une
femme pas forcément
âgée mais solitaire et peut-être vous
êtes-vous posé la question que font-ils
ou vont-elles à quoi ressemble leur vie
à rien parfois c'est du moins ce que
pensait être une Parisienne de 64 ans
ancien mannequin deux fois divorcé
accablé par les soucis financiers et qui
avait décidé de se laisser mourir de
faim dans son appartement c'est en
novembre 1984 qu'elle a pris sa décision
et ce n'est qu'hier que l'on s'est
aperçu de sa mort 9 mois plus tard
auprès d'elle dans un carnet elle avait
scrupuleusement consigné les détails de
son agonie elle était morte seule au
milieu des autres indifférents reportage
Dani espoirier et Michel janoulatos
en entrant on ne trouve déjà plus son
nom sur la boîte aux lettres Marcel
Pichon s'est laissé mourir de faim sans
que personne pendant 10 mois ne s'en
aperçoive dans un petit studio de ce
grand ensemble du 18e arrondissement une
femme de 74 ans est morte oubliée malade
de sa solitude et quand un jour sa
voisine avez-vous lu se préoccuper
d'elle il était déjà trop tard
je suis allée une proie par hasard parce
qu'elle avait une lettre à chaque porte
en dehors dans le couloir là et je
frappe chez elle je lui dis qu'elle
habite
elle a pris la lettre elle m'a pris mal
reçu
elle m'a dit faut pas comme ça parce que
je suis malade j'ai du mal à me je
m'excuse mais si vous êtes malade est-ce
que avez-vous besoin de quelque chose
je n'ai jamais entendu parler d'elle
puisque c'était presque une inconnue il
n'y a pas très longtemps qu'elle
habitait l'immeuble puis moi j'habite le
rez-de-chaussée elle elle habitait au
sixième étage vous savez je l'ai connu
je l'ai vu je l'ai connu de vue quoi
le 23 septembre dernier elle avait écrit
sur un cahier d'écoliers j'ai décidé de
me laisser mourir de faim j'ai de graves
difficultés financières et je suis là de
la vie dès lors Marcel Pichon se laisse
doucement glisser dans la mort et son
cahier des colliers la campagne le 6
novembre le carnet s'arrête sur ses mots
c'est la mort la plus horrible qui soit
on ne sait jamais la vérité
de sa jeunesse elle avait conservé ses
photos du temps où elle était mannequin
chez fate un grand couturier elle avait
eu deux enfants mais ces deux divorces
l'avaient marqué à jamais en janvier 84
elle avait participé pourrai faire 3 à
une émission d'angaillard sur la
solitude comme on lance un appel au
secours
là il faudrait quelqu'un quelqu'un pour
se confier pour partager les joies j'en
avais vu etc etc pour commencer tout à
l'heure vous m'avez dit l'humour ça
serait
ah ça serait que quelqu'un
me dise bonjour chérie et la journée
était bonne
[Musique]
puis des années personne n'attendait
plus Marcel Pichon cela se passait sous
nos yeux en plein Paris au 20e siècle
[Musique]